bienvenue à cette dernière émission de
la 28e saison de l'émission la facture
nos téléphones cellulaires sont devenus
tellement performants qu'on peut avoir
l'impression de ne plus avoir besoin
d'un véritable appareil photo mais
est-ce vraiment le cas nous faisons le
test
voici le premier téléphone cellulaire
capable de prendre des photos et de les
envoyer c'était en l'an 2000 depuis les
cellulaires ont fait des pâtes géant et
ne cesse d'évoluer au point de se
demander si les appareils photos sont
encore utiles
[Musique]
pour y voir plus clair nous avons
demandé à deux photographes de se prêter
au jeu prendre des clichés même sujet
l'homme avec un téléphone intelligent
l'autre avec un appareil photo
professionnel je travaille avec une
Canon 5D mark four je travaille
quotidiennement avec un iPhone 13 pro
Michel prou enseigne la photo depuis
plus de 40 ans en 2021 il a un déclic et
devient honnête du téléphone intelligent
il offre aujourd'hui des cours de photos
avec cellulaire moi j'appelle ça en fait
ma caméra qui peut téléphoner c'est
génial
l'enthousiasme est-elle qu'il donne 5 à
7 cours par semaine dans des
bibliothèques des centres de loisirs et
des clubs photos
ces apprentis sont souvent agréablement
surprisent c'est à peu près toujours la
même chose c'est que je pensais jamais
qu'on pouvait autant contrôler le
processus photographique avec un
téléphone
dès l'invention des premiers appareils
photos au 19e siècle les photographes
professionnels étaient les seules à
savoir les manipuler aujourd'hui tout le
monde prend des photos on parle de
milliards de photos prises chaque année
sur la planète dont de nombreuses
autoportraits des photos prises en
grande partie avec un téléphone
intelligent alors le téléphone est-ce
que ça fait une photo parfaite la
réponse c'est que ça fait une photo qui
plaît aux gens des belles couleurs des
belles couleurs saturées une belle des
petites avantages incontestable le
téléphone cellulaire est beaucoup moins
lourd qu'un appareil photo des gens plus
âgés qui partent en voyage mais ils vont
pas transporter un voyage en appareil
photo qui pèse 4 kg ils vont partir avec
la légèreté parce que à la fin pour
l'utilisation des photos qui vont en
faire ça va être tout à fait adéquat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec nos photos on
les partage Instagram Facebook on les on
les montre également quand on va voir la
famille et on les monte sur quoi sur
l'écran du téléphone alors c'est une
infime portion des gens qui ont besoin
de la haute qualité des gros appareils
photos aujourd'hui les Apple et les
Samsung de ce monde ne vendent pas qu'un
simple téléphone cellulaire il mise
d'abord et avant tout sur la puissance
de la caméra des capteurs plus grands
plus de lentilles plus de mégapixels et
même la possibilité de travailler avec
des fichiers rats comme le font les
appareils photos professionnels
n'empêche la grande différence c'est la
taille du capteur le dispositif qui
enregistre l'image le capteur d'un
téléphone est beaucoup plus petit que le
capteur d'une caméra haut de gamme ou
professionnel mais cette limite est en
partie compensée par l'intelligence
artificielle
gère la lumière société évident chez la
première chose ça permet de gérer la
mise au point plus correctement allez
faire des effets des centaines d'effets
possibles de couleurs plus vives dans
certaines situations de couleurs plus
douces plus chaud plus froide donc
l'intelligence artificielle intègre des
visions
numériques mais qui plaisent aux gens
alors si on parle de téléphone
intelligent en termes de photos de
qualité de photos c'est quoi les limites
quand on voit des marketing oh 200
mégapixels qui nous laissent présumer
qu'on va pouvoir la grandir et faire une
murale dans le salon mais ça c'est un
fichier rat un fichier rat c'est le
fichier de plus haute qualité qu'on peut
avoir dans un téléphone c'est un fichier
qui n'est pas compressé du tout on doit
le prendre et le traiter c'est pas très
grand public non c'est pas du tout grand
public si les fichiers rats permettent
de faire de grandes impressions il est
possible de faire des agrandissements
sans le mode rat sans perdre trop de
qualité mais jusqu'à une certaine limite
on peut faire imprimer des photos de
grandeur bon je vais partir où on se
quatorze avec la plupart des téléphones
récents sans vraiment de perte de
qualité mais au-delà de ça qu'est-ce qui
se produit
les pixels donc ça ça en lève la netteté
de la photo
si on étire trop les pixels
voyons maintenant comment se compare des
photos prises avec un téléphone
cellulaire un seul prise avec un
appareil professionnel Michel prou et sa
collègue Marie-José hins portraitiste de
carrière ont pour mission de croquer un
même sujet dans un cadrage similaire
dans les mêmes conditions de lumière
naturelle
[Musique]
moi personnellement quand je regarde les
deux photos je vois pas une énorme
différence sauf sur certains points la
plus grosse différence que je vois c'est
au niveau des couleurs évidemment
l'appareil de téléphone a fait ce que pu
pour travailler avec les lumières qui
étaient là donc on a une teinte verte
que je trouve un peu désagréable en
général les téléphones vont sursaturer
aussi les cheveux sont plus définis ici
mais il y a un découpage on le sent là
on pourrait dire c'est une fois il y a
fait une petite job de frisotti mais en
même temps c'est plus carré exactement
[Musique]
on peut retenir qu'on peut aller très
très proche avec un téléphone beaucoup
plus proche qu'on pense moi je vois la
différence dans le contraste et la
dureté
c'est un peu moins doux un peu moins
un peu moins plaisant à l'oeil à gauche
mais c'est très beau pareil moi je pense
que le téléphone a tenté de capter à la
fois les ombres et les lumières et puis
il y a mal géré son affaire donc ça a
donné une dominance de Magento
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup moins dramatique comme
comparatif parce que on est dans ce
pourquoi un téléphone est fait c'est à
dire de faire des photos dans des
situations
paysages reportages grand public c'est
assez similaire effectivement il
faudrait zoom on voit qu'il y a la
définition tombent vite avec le miennes
exactement c'est quoi la conclusion
est-ce que les téléphones intelligents
se comparent à un appareil professionnel
c'est évident que non cependant que
faites-vous avec vos photos
95% des gens qui prennent des photos sur
la planète on les met dans les médias
sociaux qui vont compresser l'image et
avoir une photo de qualité moyenne on va
les montrer directement sur l'écran
comme photo souvenir on va à la rigueur
des fois imprimer des albums numériques
de format plutôt moyen le téléphone est
capable de faire tout ça
[Musique]
jamais je serais capable pour l'instant
du moins avec les téléphones de faire
exactement ça avec la même qualité donc
pour le portraitiste que je suis c'est
vraiment beaucoup plus intéressant pour
moi de rester avec l'équipement
professionnel
pour les mordus de la photo et les
professionnels le téléphone intelligent
n'est pas encore tout à fait à la
hauteur n'empêche certains grands
cinéastes comme Claude Lelouch ont
commencé à tourner des films avec un
cellulaire en fait moi j'utilise le
téléphone quand est-ce que je l'utilise
bain quand je suis dans situation
sociale familiale je vais utiliser mon
téléphone en fait c'est très utile
d'avoir le téléphone avec soi parce
qu'il est petit il est portable
le meilleur appareil photo qu'on a c'est
celui qu'on a avec nous
[Musique]
selon les statistiques les consommateurs
ont déjà fait leur choix le marché de
l'appareil photo grand public c'est
littéralement effondré depuis l'arrivée
du téléphone intelligent